MALE SPEAKER: Hi, everybody.
Thanks again for coming to
another Authors at Google event
at the San Francisco office.
We're very psyched today to
welcome Rob Baedeker and Chris
Colin, both of whom are local
Bay-Areans, if that's a word.
Chris is an author
and a journalist
whose work has appeared in
the "New York Times," "Wired,"
and "McSweeney's,"
and he lives in SF.
Rob Baedeker is a performer and
a co-founder of Kasper Hauser
comedy troupe, famed for
many things, including
"Obama's BlackBerry"
and "SkyMaul,"
and also famed for
not much of anything.
He lives in Oakland.
Tony Millionaire, who's
actually not here,
but he's an illustrator who's
part of the book which they're
going to talk about today
called "What To Talk About,"
is famous for the "Sock
Monkey" series of comics
and the syndicated comic
strip "Maakies," and he
lives down south, but we
won't hold that against him.
So thanks very much, again,
for Rob and Chris, for coming
today, and please
welcome them to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
ROB BAEDEKER: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ROB BAEDEKER: Oh good,
we're off to a good start.
Thanks for coming out.
We're the authors of
"What To Talk About."
And we wrote this book that
is a little bit absurd,
but it also has a
practical element.
It's our belief that most of us
are doing all right at talking.
If you're here, you
have a job at Google,
you're doing pretty well
to have gotten here.
But most of us, we think,
have about a 10% gap
where we could improve--
CHRIS COLIN: 10 to 12.
ROB BAEDEKER: --10
to 12, thank you--
where we could push a
conversation further, start
a conversation
where we get stuck,
or take it to a memorable place.
And so we hope that
this book will give you
some tools to take
away and actually use,
as well as some flights
of absurd fancy.
Does that sound good?
All right.
We'll start with-- we have
some case studies here,
and we'll start with
one about Rachel.
Anybody know Tony Millionaire?
He does a strip called "Maakies"
and a bunch of other stuff.
Great illustrator.
CHRIS COLIN: That's a drawing.
It's not a photo.
ROB BAEDEKER: Thanks.
Virtual reality.
This is about Raquel.
Case study Raquel. "Raquel
R., a graphic designer
and aspiring artist, went
to an album release party
for a friend of a friend.
Everyone at the
party was engaging
in small talk about the
weather, their favorite bands,
and so on.
But Raquel wanted no part of it.
'Lame,' thought Raquel, popping
in earbuds and listening to her
iTunes.
'What a waste of
time.' A week later,
Raquel died in a
skydiving accident.
Raquel didn't really die.
She never existed.
We invented her to
teach you a lesson.
Life is too short to
judge other people,
or to write off opportunities
to learn from them."
CHRIS COLIN: So
yeah, I mean, you
can tell now this is sort
of a scientific enterprise.
We tried to have fun,
but that is science.
And because we
feel like we wanted
to write a fun, funny book.
But deep inside, we wanted
to get better at talking.
Like Rob said, I think
most of us are fine,
but there are those
moments-- I think
there are two key
moments in my mind
when I wanted a book like this.
One is when you're
freaking out, you're
in the elevator with someone
who you sort of remember
but you don't know their name
and you're just-- I mean,
like, every thought
drains from your head.
You cannot summon a single brain
cell to put together a word.
So there's those panic moments.
But then there's this other
kind of moment where you think,
I'm only going to
live once, probably,
and why can't every
conversation be
like that incredible,
moving, memorable one
I had in 2011 outside that
tire shop with my friend?
We went on for hours.
We went to deep places.
It was a little funny.
We got to know each other.
I've hung out with that guy,
like, 10 times since then.
Why is it sort of middling
when I see him now?
Like, I've got the
same brain, so why
can't I go back to those
great conversations?
Why can't I always have
a great dinner party?
So that's sort of
the other side of us
that I was hoping
we would write for.
I'm going to read
another case study again.
This is science.
This is from Chapter
10, our "Work" chapter.
Work is a realm where we all
need to make conversation.
This is about Marvin--
Marvin C. We changed--
we disguised their identities.
"Marvin C. has worked for
nearly two years as a software
engineer at some kind
of huge software place.
But do you want to know
Marvin's dirty little secret?
He has no idea what
software is, or engineering.
So what does Marvin know?
He knows what to talk about.
People like to see Marvin.
He's curious about them.
He's generous with his
attention, his interests.
He's even honest.
'I have no idea what software
is,' he says to co-workers.
'Tell me about it' they
laugh, as Marvin leaves.
'See you on Monday, Marvin.'"
So yeah.
Let's face it.
A lot of success
in the workplace
has nothing to do
with so-called skills.
It comes down to knowing
what to talk about
and how to talk about it.
And that's what we want
to talk about today.
ROB BAEDEKER: Marvin is
based on someone we met here.
No, he's not.
He's not.
He is.
Do you ever have
that situation where
you run into somebody here,
or at a different job,
where you feel like you
should know their name
but it's way past
the time you can ask?
We've got a strategy for that.
The Social Security
website has a list
of the most popular
birth names by year.
So all you've got to
do is guess their age,
and if you think they
were born around 1980,
you look at the top names.
And it's like, Michael,
David, and Jeffrey.
And just go bold.
Hey, Mike, how's it going?
And there's a good
chance you'll be right.
CHRIS COLIN: It's
probably right.
ROB BAEDEKER: You're
And if you're not,
you'll probably
start a conversation anyway.
Or if it's your
boss, you'll find
a new job that's
even more exciting.
One of the big things
we all worry about
is what to say when
you're on your deathbed.
How do you find
that perfect line
that's clever, a little
enigmatic, sweet,
not too dark, inspiring?
And so--
CHRIS COLIN: 'Cause this
is your last moment.
It's your moment.
You don't want to go out with a
whimper or say something lame.
ROB BAEDEKER: So we
put together a table
that, really, any combination
of these will work.
So if you just pick randomly
from column A, B, C, and D,
you get, what sled shadows.
Perfectly mysterious, right?
What did he mean?
And you can keep your
survivors entertained.
Keep this laminated
card in your pocket.
You never know when the
time's going to come.
And you'll say something
memorable, something
inspiring for your loved ones.
CHRIS COLIN: Because we
do want to be memorable.
That is what we want in life.
We want to connect with people.
We want to make an impression.
We want them to make
an impression on us.
ROB BAEDEKER: "The
mirror life beagle."
Again, perfectly appropriate.
We're not only-- it's kind of
a "physician, heal thyself"
situation.
Chris and I need to work
on this, as you can tell.
And so we wrote a book,
but we're doing research
and we're finding out
what are the roadblocks.
Where do people get stuck
when you have talk to people?
So we want to hear from you now.
And we just want to
gather some data.
When you're at a party,
when you're at work,
think about a situation where
you're talking to someone,
or trying to talk to someone,
and think about them.
And we'd like to hear a
few reports from the field.
Where does it get stuck?
What does the other person do
that makes conversations stall
or not start in the first place?
What have you experienced?
CHRIS COLIN: Your conversation
partner gives quick answers.
They don't elaborate.
It's like no forward
progress has occurred.
Yes.
ROB BAEDEKER: Thank you.
What else?
AUDIENCE: They don't stop
talking about themselves.
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah.
They can't stop talking
about themselves.
Number one complaint we've
heard in our research.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Sometimes it's a
dog that I try to talk to.
CHRIS COLIN:
Sometimes it's a dog.
And what happens?
AUDIENCE: They usually
don't say anything.
CHRIS COLIN: You get nowhere.
That's not as common, but
that is a real problem.
ROB BAEDEKER: The "mirror life
beagle," Dogs love that one.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Sometimes I
lose track of what they're
talking about after the
third or fourth kid.
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah.
They-- third or fourth what?
Kid?
AUDIENCE: Third or
fourth kid, yeah.
ROB BAEDEKER: Oh yeah.
It's adjacent to
the self-involvement
that it's all about their kids.
They can be cute, for a while.
AUDIENCE: Stuff you
just don't care about.
ROB BAEDEKER: Stuff you
For example?
AUDIENCE: Kardashians.
ROB BAEDEKER: Kardashians.
Let's skip our
Kardashian chapter.
CHRIS COLIN: OK, yeah.
ROB BAEDEKER: It's
irrelevant to you, right?
But they go on and on.
What else?
CHRIS COLIN: OK.
What about you?
What about when things
go south on your end,
and you don't--
you're panicking,
or you're just sort of not
doing as well as you want,
or maybe in retrospect you
wish you had done better.
Are there things that
you feel like you--
areas where you sort of blow it?
No shame.
We're all friends here.
AUDIENCE: Swearing.
CHRIS COLIN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Swearing accidentally.
CHRIS COLIN: Swearing
accidentally?
ROB BAEDEKER: We can
help you with that.
CHRIS COLIN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Swearing
intentionally.
ROB BAEDEKER: In the back?
AUDIENCE: Adding
too much detail,
so you're losing your audience.
CHRIS COLIN: That's a good
one, adding too much detail.
You say too much,
and pretty soon you
realize they're not even
standing there anymore.
AUDIENCE: Not knowing
a good question to ask.
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah, not
knowing a good question to ask.
That sort of bonking that
cyclists and runners talk
about?
You're just sort of--
the blood sugar drains,
and you're left frozen.
That happens to me sometimes.
And the rabbit hole, right?
You go down your own
rabbit hole of detail.
Any others that you see in
other people, or that you do?
AUDIENCE: And to be fair, I
should probably say that I also
talk about things that
they don't care about.
Just to be fair.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
distracted?
ROB BAEDEKER: Being distracted?
You're distracted, or
they're distracted?
AUDIENCE: Either.
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah.
Yeah.
Hold on, I want--
yeah, what was it?
That one?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
simple question,
and you can't answer it.
ROB BAEDEKER: They ask you
a simple question you--
AUDIENCE: Even when you have
plenty of things to talk about.
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah,
like what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Maybe
the hardest is when
someone asks about
something I have
no idea about the
subject matter.
So that's usually where I stall.
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah.
When you don't
know-- and I don't
know if you're saying
this-- but for me,
I'm afraid of not
knowing the answer
or saying something stupid.
Is there another one over here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a
tendency to start
thinking about something
else when somebody's talking,
and realize afterwards
that I don't actually
know what they said.
CHRIS COLIN: Do you always
think about the same thing?
Is it always one
topic you go to?
AUDIENCE: Whatever
tends to be on my mind
or something I'm worrying about.
ROB BAEDEKER: So your
mind's wandering.
Does that happen even
if they're interesting,
or do they do something
that makes you tune out?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure.
I think sometimes it
might be that I'm not
extremely interested
in what they're saying,
or there's something else
that's kind of on my mind.
But it doesn't mean I
didn't want to listen.
It's just that I accidentally
stopped listening.
ROB BAEDEKER: I love this point.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Jeff.
ROB BAEDEKER: Jeff?
So Jeff's saying
something key here.
I didn't want to stop listening,
but my mind just went away.
That's what this is about,
those moments where you actually
want to listen.
We're going to give you some
ideas for that in a minute.
AUDIENCE: When
you're trying to find
a topic that both people
are interested in,
and it just comes off as awkward
standing there [INAUDIBLE].
ROB BAEDEKER: Trying to find
a mutually interesting topic.
Do you have an example in mind?
AUDIENCE: If you're meeting
with someone you don't really
know very well,
you're at a conference
or on a first date
or something, you're
trying to start a conversation.
And sometimes things
just get awkward.
[INAUDIBLE] how's the weather?
Eventually that gets boring.
ROB BAEDEKER:
"How's the weather?"
gets boring pretty
quickly, especially here.
AUDIENCE: When you use up
those four words of Russian
that you knew and
then you're at a loss
because you can't
communicate anymore.
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah,
travel situations
where your language is limited.
We have a chapter on that.
AUDIENCE: For me,
sometimes when I'm at work,
and someone will ask me a
question about something,
and my mind will go to a
not-safe-for-work story.
I get stuck on it,
and I can't think
of how to say something else.
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah, so how
do you keep it appropriately
work respectable but
still interesting?
So, Chris, you've been
parsing this data.
And I think we hear
these patterns a lot
when we were writing the book
and when we talked to people.
And they're pretty
common patterns.
CHRIS COLIN: Yeah.
I mean, what I'm hearing
is stuff that we heard all
over the course of the 12 years
it took to write this book.
It's similar stuff.
And I think it's sort
of-- what I'm hearing
is it breaks down into sort of
two or maybe three sections.
There's how do you
start a conversation?
How do you get it going?
How do you just get
it into first gear?
And then once you're going,
how do you remain interesting,
how do you remain
interested, how do you not
curse accidentally
or intentionally?
Once things are sort of humming,
how do you keep it there?
And then there's one that
didn't really come up yet,
but I feel like you
were about to say this.
How do you get out
of a conversation?
Either one that--
ROB BAEDEKER: Anyone
have that challenge?
CHRIS COLIN: How do you get
out of a great conversation,
but you're just done?
Or, how do you get out
of a crappy conversation?
ROB BAEDEKER: So we're
going to give you
some tools that will help you in
the beginning, middle, and end.
You can put these
to work right now
and automatically elevate the
quality of your conversations
by about 6%.
You guys interested?
Great.
First one is beginnings.
CHRIS COLIN: So getting
into a conversation,
I think that's where we--
maybe that's the highest
concentration of panic.
They're standing there, you're
at a party, you're at work,
you're at a family
gathering, and there's
someone you don't
really know that well.
It's a glancing
relationship with the woman
who checks your gas
meter or whatever,
and you feel like you've
got to say something.
And I think a lot of us--
that panic sort of morphs
into the sense that
the stakes are high.
This has got to be something
really good that I'm saying.
And the more seconds that
pass, the higher the bar
goes-- oh my god, I've
now waited four seconds.
I've got to say
something really good.
This is getting weird.
I definitely can't ask
about the weather right now.
And that's where we feel
like, actually-- well,
the first step is
lowering the bar.
And the way you do that
is understanding something
that I think we all
know and lose sight of.
Everyone wants to connect.
We're all idiots.
No one knows what we're-- we
don't know what we're doing.
We're all winging it.
When you think about it,
conversation is this thing.
It's the glue in every
situation-- professional,
social, romantic, other things
that don't have words for them.
And yet no one really
teaches it to us.
There's no finishing
school for conversation.
They teach you to talk up
until, like, age three,
and then they just sort
of throw you in the water.
And I think what
bears remembering
is that we're all in
the same situation.
Some of us pass better
as competent people,
but none of us is
actually competent.
So when you go into a
social situation with that
in mind, that can help sort of
take the edge off a little bit.
And then you do
what we recommend,
which is like an on-ramp.
Picture getting
onto the highway.
You don't start at 60.
You go slow.
Small talk gets sort of
pooh-poohed in our culture.
We pooh-pooh the
pooh-poohing because we
think small talk is actually a
very safe, nonthreatening way
to establish really important
visual, nonverbal information
about ourselves.
I'm not a threatening person.
I am a threatening person.
I would like to have a serious
conversation right here.
This is going to be very brief.
Let's not get into it.
We're establishing all
these things just by saying,
I really like the weather, or
where did you get those shoes.
And so no shame in saying really
boring things because it's
just going to last
for a few moments.
And pretty soon you're on
your way to something else.
ROB BAEDEKER: Who had the
point about closed-off answers
that close the conversation?
This is our next tool, which
is cold openings-- questions
or starting lines that
are a little more open,
that allow people
to tell stories,
get beyond the weather, get
beyond yes and no questions.
And we're going to
give you a few examples
and actually let you try them.
Here's one we recommend.
If you had an additional eye
in the middle of your back,
and you were online
dating, would you
mention it in your profile
or wait till the first date?
We want to see what you think.
Take 20 seconds, if
you would, and turn
to someone sitting next
to you, and ask them
and get their opinion.
We're going to see
what the results are.
Literally 20 seconds.
20 seconds each.
Ask someone sitting next to you.
[CHATTER]
Who said mention
it in your profile?
You're the only guy that's
going to mention it?
Two people.
Who said wait till
the first date?
A lot of you didn't vote.
AUDIENCE: Third date.
ROB BAEDEKER: Oh, third date.
Thinking outside the question.
Let me get another read.
Who said mention
it in your profile?
About 27%.
Who said mention it
when you have the date?
First date?
Still not voting.
Second date?
Third date, is that-- oh, OK.
Wow.
For those of you said
online profile, why?
AUDIENCE: Because it
weeds out all the people
that wouldn't be cool with
it in the first place.
Just get it out front.
It's going to happen
at some point.
You might as well just
weed out the people
before you start having
three dates with them.
CHRIS COLIN: A sieve.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
attract weirdos
who just want to see it.
ROB BAEDEKER: It
won't attract weirdos
who just want to see it?
AUDIENCE: Well, um--
AUDIENCE: That's pretty
discriminatory to weirdos.
AUDIENCE: So for those that
would wait till the first date,
how would you just
bring it out there?
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah, let's
hear your logic here.
Who said wait till
the first date?
How would you bring it up?
AUDIENCE: Or third or fourth.
Being that my third eye
isn't that big of a deal,
so I don't want to
be prejudged for it.
I'd like them to like me first
before they judge my third eye.
ROB BAEDEKER: Did you hear that?
Try to downplay
the significance.
AUDIENCE: What is your date
that your back is exposed?
What are you doing?
ROB BAEDEKER: What are
you doing on the date
that your back is exposed?
AUDIENCE: As a first date.
Yeah, let's go swimming
for the first date, whoo.
ROB BAEDEKER: You're riding
a tandem bike shirtless
up Telegraph Hill.
Obviously.
Here's the second question.
Worst sunburn you've ever had?
20 seconds.
Exchange stories.
Go.
[CHATTER]
Do you have a good
sunburn story?
Or did you hear one?
AUDIENCE: As a kid running
around for hours [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS COLIN: We're
hearing a sunburn story.
AUDIENCE: The one blister
kind of experience on my back.
Kind of a couple of blisters,
but that was the worst,
and I'll never do it again.
Probably took five
years off my life.
ROB BAEDEKER: How old were
you during this sunburn?
AUDIENCE: Must have been
about eight or nine or so.
ROB BAEDEKER: Eight or nine.
Anybody else?
CHRIS COLIN: And I'm
sorry, where was this?
AUDIENCE: It was in Argentina.
CHRIS COLIN: OK.
All right.
ROB BAEDEKER: There's a
lot more there, I feel.
AUDIENCE: There's a lot
more sun, and I was a kid.
Back in those days,
you didn't really
put so much suntan cream on.
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah,
our parents just-- go.
Go in the sun.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
ROB BAEDEKER:
Shouldn't be a problem.
Did anybody hear a good
one, or tell a good one?
Worst sunburn?
CHRIS COLIN: OK.
Let's dive in right there.
I mean, already, let's say
that you said this question
to someone at a--
like a roller disco.
And someone says this to you.
Already, you're
off to the races.
You can ask-- what's your name?
AUDIENCE: James.
CHRIS COLIN: James?
You can ask James
about Argentina.
You can ask about childhood.
You can ask about sun.
You can ask about what kind
of parenting strategies
he grew up under.
Pretty soon, you're taking
sort of a jokey thing
and you are connecting it
to the stuff we care about,
which is life.
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah.
The possibilities
start to branch out.
Here's the last one.
How do you pronounce this word?
Everybody see it?
Five seconds.
See if your partner knows.
Go.
[CHATTER]
CHRIS COLIN: I want to know
who feels the most confident.
Raise your hand if you feel
like you might be the person who
can say it with the
most confidence.
You feel very
confident about this.
AUDIENCE: "In-cho-ate."
ROB BAEDEKER: "In-ko-ate."
"In-ko-ate" or "in-cho-ate?"
AUDIENCE: "In-cho-ate."
CHRIS COLIN: OK.
So already we have
something we can talk about.
Why does this woman
feel so confident?
What's her deal?
Like, where did she grow up?
What contributed to
this weird personality
where she just feels so
confident about the way she
says this word?
AUDIENCE: It also means--
ROB BAEDEKER: Go.
AUDIENCE: Origin of German, and
it means to-- when you drive
and suddenly stop.
That's what it means.
ROB BAEDEKER: It means when
you drive and suddenly stop?
AUDIENCE: It's like
[INAUDIBLE] stop.
You have a bad brake
at a stop sign.
That person didn't [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS COLIN: OK.
So now we know she's got some
real issues, like with honesty.
So that's something--
pretty soon,
you would be having a
pretty intense conversation,
I imagine.
A pretty inchoate conversation.
AUDIENCE: So how
do you suggest we
go about using this as
a cold opening, though?
Because it seems like
we'd have to walk around
with little note
cards, be like--
CHRIS COLIN: Bingo.
AUDIENCE: --pronounce
this for me.
It's important.
ROB BAEDEKER: You
got to write it down.
You got to write it down.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, I actually have
a friend who has a shirt with
the letters N-I-C-H-E on it
that he likes to wear and go up
to people and say, how
do you pronounce this?
CHRIS COLIN: That's good.
So I know what
you're asking, and I
think it's a really
good question.
Because you don't want to seem
like sort of a skeezy person
who goes around
with lines, right?
Because who wants to
talk to that person?
That's disingenuous.
So I think this
gets at something
that I think is sort
of core to our book.
You sort of have to
check in with yourself
before you have a conversation.
And I think it
can be hard to do,
because you do get caught
up in the pacing of it
or the anxiety, if it's
an anxious conversation.
And you sort of forget every
single thing about yourself.
Like, what do I think?
What are my actual interests?
I'm just trying to keep
this conversation going.
You forget who you are.
But I think if you can
take a moment-- and one
thing I recommend,
if you're, say,
meeting someone for a beer,
instead of getting there
four minutes late, get
there four minutes early.
Put your phone in your pocket.
Walk around the block.
You don't actually to
try to have a thought.
You just have to walk
around the block.
And the systems will start
to sort of come online again.
And instead of taking in
information while you wait,
you will sort of, even without
trying, check in with yourself.
So why does this matter in
terms of saying skeezy opening
lines to people?
Because you'll be checking
in with that core curiosity
and that sort of genuine
interest in people.
You really do want to
know about their sunburn.
If we're all honest,
if we can really
sort of check in with ourselves,
just to use some Northern
California language
there, I think
we'll find that we
care about people.
We want to connect.
We're not skeezy.
I mean, maybe a
couple people, but--
[LAUGHTER]
No, but in all seriousness,
we're not skeezy.
We just want to
make conversation.
And I think that if you ask
the same question, having
sort of connected with that
genuine part of yourself,
it will not seem
like a canned line.
Or it will, but it
will be forgiven.
ROB BAEDEKER: Great.
Let's go on to the middle.
What happens in the middle
is you bonk out, right?
Somebody said it.
You draw a blank.
You have an awkward moment.
And you bail.
Or you say something
work-inappropriate.
Or something else gets
you off the rails.
So strategies for the middle.
To keep the momentum going,
to keep their interest,
to keep your interest-- if
your mind is wandering-- here
are a few.
The first one is
do your homework.
Do some research.
And you can think about three
things to bring to a party,
or to a lunch, or
anywhere where you
know you might need
something to talk about.
And we're going to give
you some things as well.
The first one is--
and these are obvious,
but we don't do this--
something you read in the news.
Something's going on about
that plane in Malaysia,
about Crimea.
Read the first paragraph.
That'll jump start
your conversation,
and you can ask questions.
A big idea.
So it doesn't need
to be topical,
but something happening
in the world, a trend,
something you want the other
person's opinion about.
And finally, fail
safe, something cute
your pet did or your kid did.
Three or four kids, it gets old.
But it's usually interesting
for at least one, especially
if the other person
has a pet or a kid.
Now, we've got
here some research
for you and some tools.
Maybe you could just
pass these back.
These are cards that you
can use in the middle.
And you'll find prompts on them.
And there's something to
notice about the prompts.
And it's the same
idea behind how do you
pronounce "inchoate"?
There's a comfort
with ignorance.
We've got to admit we
don't know everything.
And even point that
out in ourselves,
because it lowers the bar.
Too many people
get hung up on how
to feel like they're
smart, whether they come
across as intelligent,
that they know everything.
And we're afraid
to admit I don't
know how to pronounce this word.
Or I don't know what's
going on in Crimea.
Or I don't know
what a tornado is.
Help me out, right?
If you've got a card,
and you're sitting
next to someone who also
has a card, pass it back.
So every pair should
have one card.
And if you don't have a
card, raise your hand,
so the folks in the
back can get one.
And, again, we want to gather
data on what works here
and what doesn't work.
So pair up, find
somebody with a card,
and take 20 seconds
each to weigh
in on the question on your card.
And we're going
to see what works.
So, 20 seconds, go for it.
[CHATTER]
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Victoria.
ROB BAEDEKER: Victoria,
what was your question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, so we
didn't get to mine--
AUDIENCE: We did my question.
AUDIENCE: Oh, thank you.
Mine was the best
thing you've ever done,
but we actually used
Louella's question.
ROB BAEDEKER: Louella,
what was yours?
AUDIENCE: Who do you think
talked about you most recently,
and what did they say?
ROB BAEDEKER: Ooh.
Juicy.
Do you want to
share your answer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So we
decided it had to be
something bad that was said.
So we go into this juice--
so I'm from the Bay Area.
And there was this girl
from my high school
who had a falling out with
me like three years ago.
And I recently
went out to drinks
with one of our mutual friends,
completely separate from her,
and she freaked out about it and
was trying to basically swing
this girl to not
be friends with me.
So that was like the juice.
ROB BAEDEKER: Wow, a
campaign of terror.
That opens up a lot
of possibilities.
Bay Area, high school, you
can go in many directions.
How about you guys here, UCLA?
What did you guys talk about?
AUDIENCE: True or false?
Washing your chicken just
splatters the bacteria
everywhere.
ROB BAEDEKER: Washing your
chicken, before you cook it,
just splatters the
bacteria everywhere.
CHRIS COLIN: Works against you.
ROB BAEDEKER: True.
AUDIENCE: And we
basically talked
about how you
wouldn't necessarily
wash your chicken for bacteria.
It would just-- as you
cook it, it would just die.
ROB BAEDEKER: Great.
I love this.
Questioning the premise
of the question.
Right?
And that led you to-- did
you get into any cooking?
AUDIENCE: So we're
wondering why you
would wash your chicken
for other reasons.
ROB BAEDEKER: You have
the myriad reasons
you would wash your
chicken, aside from cooking.
So this is an actual
thing, that we're
used to washing our chicken,
but it's counterproductive.
AUDIENCE: I grew up on a farm.
I was thinking actual chicken.
ROB BAEDEKER: Great.
Now I want to hear about
the farm you grew up on.
We're off and running.
Or that stalled conversation
has suddenly got some momentum.
OK.
We're going to look
at two more strategies
quickly for jump starting a
conversation in the middle.
Chris is going to
walk us through these.
CHRIS COLIN: So curiosity.
Like I said, curiosity
has got to be
at the heart of your heart
when you talk to someone.
And it's not just any curiosity.
I think the kind
of curiosity that
works best, that elicits
the best kind of responses,
is a curiosity for stories.
I think that's what
we all want to hear.
Everyone likes a story.
What we don't like is boring,
sort of abstract ideas,
if they're not couched
in terms of a story.
Let's say you're camping.
You've got two campfires here.
Everyone can picture a campfire.
Here's one, and someone's
just about to talk around
the campfire about
(MOCK WEARY TONE) god,
San Francisco's not
the same anymore.
It's all changing.
All this new money's coming in.
So you could hear
that conversation.
Or you go to this campfire and
someone says, once upon a time.
Which one do you like?
Having heard those
little snippets,
which one do you choose?
AUDIENCE: Once upon a time.
CHRIS COLIN: Once
upon a time, right?
What we like is sequence.
This is our theory at
what to talk about.
People like to hear
a sequence of events.
They like to hear a narrative.
So when you're
deploying your curiosity
in a conversation, don't just
say, what are you all about?
That's too abstract.
What do you think about
San Francisco these days?
Too abstract.
I prefer something
smaller but concrete,
with a sequence involved.
What's your morning like?
What's your morning routine?
Mine is sort of screwy.
I don't know, I'm
running around,
trying to get breakfast,
get the kids' lunch made,
have to have a little
argument with my wife.
And then find--
then run to the bus.
Why am I always
running to the bus?
I don't know.
I know what time it comes.
Why am I always late?
Pretty soon you get sort
of a narrative going.
And you can ask someone, what's
your standard morning like?
How did you get to
this party tonight?
And pretty soon,
they're saying something
that ostensibly doesn't
seem interesting.
But they're walking you
through concrete steps.
And then pretty soon, you're
both on each other's hooks.
ROB BAEDEKER: Great.
And the final strategy
for the middle?
Shoes.
CHRIS COLIN: Shoes.
You do shoes.
ROB BAEDEKER: Shoes
are about noticing
what's going on in the
moment and generating
conversation out of it.
So everybody's wearing
shoes or not wearing shoes.
Something's going on down there.
Ask a question about it.
Where did you get your shoes?
That's a cool color.
What do you call it?
What's your favorite
pair of shoes?
There are a million
stories in footwear.
There's something kind
of primal about it.
But don't limit
yourself to shoes.
Notice what's going on.
I see that you're
holding your back.
Have you had back
trouble lately?
You're smiling.
Are you thinking
of something funny?
This is the
in-the-moment strategy.
And there are a billion offers.
We call these offers in the
world of improvisation--
noticing what's going
on and giving someone
the gift of curiosity.
Asking about those real things.
OK.
We're going to give
you one more tool.
And this is a tool, again,
you can pull out at a party,
at lunch, when you
go back to your desk.
We're going to ask you
to create a life motto.
A life motto.
But the trick is it
doesn't have to be
clever or funny or interesting.
It just has to be
a collaboration.
And Chris and I will
demonstrate this for you.
But you're going to do
it one word at a time.
And we'll show you
how this works.
And you'll do it
either with one or two
partners, so two
or three of you.
And the life motto is
just one word at a time.
And again, you follow
whatever's going on.
We'll try it now.
CHRIS COLIN: No overthinking it.
You just go for it.
ROB BAEDEKER: Our
life motto is--
CHRIS COLIN: Always--
ROB BAEDEKER: Go--
CHRIS COLIN: To--
ROB BAEDEKER: The--
CHRIS COLIN: Store--
ROB BAEDEKER: When--
CHRIS COLIN: You're--
ROB BAEDEKER: Hungry.
CHRIS COLIN: Done.
Life motto.
ROB BAEDEKER: There you go.
That's our life motto.
It's good advice, right?
And we just discovered
that together.
Pair up.
You only have 10
seconds to do this.
A life motto doesn't have
to be funny or clever
or even make sense.
You just have to come up with
whatever you create together.
Life motto, one word at a time.
Everybody got it?
Go.
[CHATTER]
So Robin, would you mind
sharing the life motto you
and-- what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Rob.
ROB BAEDEKER: Rob?
AUDIENCE: Life motto--
ROB BAEDEKER: So Robin and
Rob put together a life motto.
And here it is.
AUDIENCE: When the sun sets
over the city, smile heavily.
ROB BAEDEKER: When the sun sets
Bravo.
CHRIS COLIN: Nice, nice.
Good one.
ROB BAEDEKER: Anybody
else have one?
AUDIENCE: Life is a
beach ball of sand.
ROB BAEDEKER: Life is
a beach ball of sand.
Bravo.
CHRIS COLIN: True.
ROB BAEDEKER: One more, to
cap off our life mottoes?
You guys got one?
CHRIS COLIN: We
got one right here.
AUDIENCE: Don't wear pink
if your father says so.
ROB BAEDEKER: Don't wear
pink if your father says so.
Bravo.
CHRIS COLIN: Unassailable.
ROB BAEDEKER: Which brings us
to the end of conversations.
CHRIS COLIN: OK, you're having
a wonderful conversation
at a friend of a friend's party.
It's been going on
for six minutes.
You can't believe how
interesting this thing is.
And you just got to--
you got to end it.
You're sick of it.
You're having fun.
There's nothing wrong with
it, but you're sick of it.
You got to get out of there.
Or you're just so--
you can't believe
you're stuck talking this
person that's so boring.
I mean, it's like
they just don't
have a single thought
in their head.
They're not interesting.
What do they do all day?
I mean, it seems like they've
never had a life experience.
You want to get out of there.
Both situations, you
don't want to be rude.
You're not an animal.
You're not a monster.
How do you end it?
It's the same for any
situation, any conversation.
It was so nice talking to you.
Exit.
ROB BAEDEKER: And
that's the end.
CHRIS COLIN: And
what does that do?
You're ending with confidence.
It's a decisive, clean break.
Look, you've been friendly.
You've been disarming.
You've exposed yourself
during this conversation.
You connected as a human.
Those are all great things.
But you want to end
confidently and cleanly
and walk away and do what?
ROB BAEDEKER: Go ride your
bike up Telegraph Hill
without your shirts on.
CHRIS COLIN: Right.
ROB BAEDEKER: Thanks
for coming out.
Do you guys have questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It was so
nice talking to you,
but now I have to--
or just full-stop?
ROB BAEDEKER: It was
so nice talking to you.
Full stop.
AUDIENCE: So no excuse, nothing.
ROB BAEDEKER:
That's the bold way.
But "now I have to"
is another option.
Now I have to go to a movie.
Bye.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What about
when you can't walk away?
ROB BAEDEKER: What about
when you can't walk away.
You're in an elevator
or a submarine.
AUDIENCE: Like, the person
next to you on an airplane.
ROB BAEDEKER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You strike up the
conversation before takeoff.
CHRIS COLIN: That's
why you have this book.
AUDIENCE: But you [LAUGHS]
CHRIS COLIN: OK?
You can open it-- it was
so nice talking to you.
AUDIENCE: Some people
don't take the hint.
ROB BAEDEKER: You
guys said what to her?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROB BAEDEKER: You can
still use the line, right?
You have to find a way to
break that's not walking away.
AUDIENCE: Go to the
bathroom, I guess.
CHRIS COLIN: Slippery
slope, the bathroom thing.
AUDIENCE: So could you talk
about the meticulous research
and the shockingly
over-specific numbers you quote?
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah, how did
we do our research and--
AUDIENCE: How did
you arrive at that?
ROB BAEDEKER: How did we
arrive at those numbers?
Well, we used big data.
[LAUGHTER]
What else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that's really weird.
CHRIS COLIN: Yeah,
that's a good question.
How do you get into
these weird questions?
I would say two things.
One, don't be afraid
of being weird.
We're all weird.
Let it show.
And two, you can create a
little segue, a little pivot.
Wow, I was just-- this
is going to sound weird.
I was having this question--
this question in my mind.
Or I was-- refer
to a conversation
you had the other
day with your aunt.
We were talking about chicken.
Can I ask you this question
we were talking about?
ROB BAEDEKER: But
context matters, right?
The chicken question might
not work in a job interview.
You've got to read
your audience.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: A friend of mine was
in his med school interviews,
or maybe residency,
one of the two.
And the person interviewing
him asked about his hobbies.
And he's like, oh, well,
I really love to juggle,
and he was being facetious.
And this guy goes on to talk
about how he is basically
a semi-professional juggler.
ROB BAEDEKER:
That's what we call
in the business the
Juggler's Conundrum.
There's no way out.
It's checkmate.
You're done.
AUDIENCE: I think it's great
that you wrote this book.
But what about the
conversation haters?
For instance, libraries.
You can't have a
conversation there.
Muni.
Even Google buses
have banned it.
CHRIS COLIN: That's
a good question.
ROB BAEDEKER: Great question.
CHRIS COLIN: I mean,
in all seriousness,
there's lots of
situations where you don't
want to be having
a conversation.
Maybe you are in a library.
Maybe you're shy.
You don't feel like talking.
Yeah, these are things that
we address in the book.
ROB BAEDEKER: The
important thing
is when you want to have a
conversation and you're not.
It's not happening.
So if you don't want to talk,
and that's working for you,
carry on.
It's great.
But our theory is
that most of us
have that 10%, 11% of time where
we wish we could've connected,
where we feel like we
missed an interesting story
or the opportunity
to meet someone.
So that's what this book is for.
CHRIS COLIN: But it's true.
You know, if you're a situation
where you don't want to talk
or it feels
inappropriate, own it.
No apologies for
not wanting to talk.
That's fine.
ROB BAEDEKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm
curious if you have
a chapter on how to navigate
awkward conversations.
Because once my sister was on
a date, and the guy kept on,
any time there was a silence,
he was like "awkward silence.
Awkward silence."
And then I also, even with the
"it's nice talking to you,"
I'm an admin, and so
people always come up to me
and feel like they can chat
with me for hours on end,
which is nice.
But I've gotten really good
at being like, oh, so nice
talking to you.
I'll see you later.
And they're like (MOCK
DOOFUS VOICE) OK.
And they'll just linger.
And I've gotten good at
putting on my headphones
and being like, OK, I really
have to do some work now.
So do you have any suggestions
or anything in your book?
ROB BAEDEKER: Well, I think you
answered your second question
for yourself.
I have to do some work.
I'll see you later.
For the first one, the guy
that fills every silence
with "awkward," a
recommendation is this.
[LAUGHTER]
Is there one more question?
AUDIENCE: Topics to bring
up with your boss's boss's
boss in the elevator.
ROB BAEDEKER: Best
and worst topics
to bring up with your
boss's boss's boss's boss.
They've probably got
some interesting shoes.
So that's a good place to start.
The context matters, right?
A, do you want to talk to them?
And B, what your purpose here?
If it's just to connect,
then something small.
Shoes, a news story, a question,
of which you have many.
If you've got a broader
context, then you
need to be ready for that.
You need to prepare,
depending on what
you want to have happen.
If you've got a goal in
mind, be strategic about it
and prepare those topics.
CHRIS COLIN: Well, let's talk
about goals, for example.
Let's say you're
angling for something.
You want to do a little sort
of jujitsu or something.
Maybe you want to
undermine the boss.
This is a controversial
recommendation,
but maybe you want to
do a subtle undermining
to throw off the
power differential.
Tell me your question again.
AUDIENCE: Seriously?
CHRIS COLIN: No, no, I
mean, repeat the question.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to know
the best and worst topics
that you should bring--
CHRIS COLIN: What?
See?
See, when I say "what,"
it throws things off.
So your boss's boss's
boss's boss says something.
I'm sorry, what?
They're not accustomed to that.
It throws things off.
And then the playing
field is a little leveler.
ROB BAEDEKER: That
brings us to our end.
It was so nice talking to you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS COLIN: Thanks, guys.